wash and learn
is a combination of libraries
and laundromats coming together with
communities
to promote literacy and help early
childhood learning
in spaces that might not normally be
traditionally thought of as libraries
i'm really excited to be here today this
morning on a saturday morning in a st
paul public library we're partnering
with libraries without borders
to ensure that all of our children and
families in our community have access to
books and literacy
and you know two hours spent on a
saturday morning washing
are also two hours spent on a saturday
morning learning
nnlm worked with us libraries outporters
to pilot our first ever laundromat event
in minnesota and with some of the
learnings from that program we
said why can't we do this across the
state and now we're working in five
different counties
seven different laundromats to
really think about how do we get
information to people where they are
how do we ensure that nnlm resources
reach the families that they're intended
to serve
this is a very natural space for
families to already be and to go to
weekly
and so we figured let's destroy
the transportation barrier or the time
barrier or whatever the obstacle is
and then come to where they are so that
we can provide them the resources that
we have
when people come into the laundromat
they're not thinking about learning
they're not thinking about addressing
their concerns about diabetes or
hypertension
or cancer they're washing their clothes
and so what we're trying to do is to
transform
the 90 minutes the wash and dry cycle
that you're doing every week
into to a different kind of experience
into one that's
actually enriching digital literacy
is fundamental to being successful in
the world today
and i think many of us take for granted
the fact that we have computers at home
that we have access to wi-fi
the national library of medicine a lot
of people aren't aware of the degree
and nature of the resources that they
put out to make learning about
topics related to medicine really
accessible to people so
we've got some websites that are set up
to the nlm site i should say
where people can look for information
about nutrition some of the resources
are directed toward kids so they're
really friendly more of a game like
environment
it was really fun because i got to play
on the computer
it was nice of them for putting all the
stuff up
it's a way to give back simply put if i
can serve my community
in the end it's going to be good for me
but the reality of it is
it's just good for the community